[Musique]
c'est un des très rares territoires du
genre en Europe des paysages vastes
encore sauvages semblables à ceux du
Grand Nord canadien mais ici comme
ailleurs les besoins en ressources
naturelles des gens du Sud n'ont pas de
frontières
[Musique]
éolienne entre en conflit avec le mode
de vie des premiers habitants
Christine Yama a grandi sur ses terres
au sein d'une famille d'éleveur de
Rennes
et les maintenant ministre au sein du
gouvernement territorial Sami Pasteur
[Musique]
parallèlement et curieusement la
bataille pour la survie de la culture
traditionnelle Samy se vit aussi en
ville
[Musique]
et là Maria est à Isaac scène artiste et
militante pour l'environnement
originaire des territoires nordiques
Sami elle a fait le choix de vivre dans
la capitale
Oslo pour mieux développer son art et
essayer d'en vivre
la culture Sami est fragile sa survie
passe d'abord par l'apprentissage de la
langue selon elle
fait la plupart des familles vivent
aujourd'hui en ville et ne parle que
très peu leur langue d'origine
[Musique]
les amis considèrent que leur mode de
vie traditionnel est fragilisé par le
développement éolien leur langue et leur
culture aussi ils ont donc contesté la
décision du gouvernement norvégien
d'autoriser ce projet
et ils ont obtenu gain de cause une
décision exceptionnelle rendue par la
plus haute cour du pays
[Musique]
on the side
militant Sami de longue date et
professeur de droit constitutionnel
considère que le jugement rendu implique
un retrait pur et simple de toutes les
tours éoliennes du territoire autochtone
même si cela va à l'encontre de la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
[Musique]
le gouvernement de gauche en Norvège et
dans l'embarras coincé entre ces
préoccupations environnementales et le
respect des droits ancestraux des
premières
nationsmbi est aussi un chanteur réputé
de yoick
dans le Grand Nord norvégien il témoigne
d'un héritage culturel qui refait
surface depuis quelques décennies
les amis ont eux aussi vécu leur épisode
de pensionnat religieux ou la culture
autochtone était imposée
mais selon cette spécialiste de la
littérature Sami une réelle
revalorisation des traditions est en
marche
que la survie culturelle de son peuple
est possible et que le jugement de la
Cour suprême en est la preuve elle pense
retourner vivre dans les territoires des
Samis un jour
Christine Yama continue son combat
politique jusqu'à ce que les tours
éoliennes soient complètement démantelés
culturelle passe d'abord par le maintien
des activités traditionnelles comme
l'élevage des reines grâce au jugement
de la Cour suprême de Norvège
[Musique]